for more than half a century the Porsche
911 has remained true to its original
concept few sports cars have rear
mounted engines these days but the 911
still remains the epitome of speed and
sporting elegance easton see here untied
simmerman is sitting in a very special
Porsche 911 the latest Targa 4s it's
undergone a facelift and a turbocharged
engine has now replaced its naturally
aspirated predecessor then of course the
target is a convertible with a fixed
roll bar that leaves Andre with two
questions how well does a Porsche like
this with a downsized turbo engine
really work and is the target design
with its rhobar up-to-date
this test Tyga concept when two people
hold Google Hoyt sitar gangster on side
commit let's start with the engine the
latest Targa 4s has a new 3 liter engine
down from the previous 3.8 liters but
thanks to the turbocharger the smaller
engine in fact boasts 15 kilowatts more
power than its predecessor while fuel
consumption is down by one liter per 100
kilometers at least according to the
--use NEDC driving cycle but that
increased efficiency only really comes
into play on longer journeys at a
constant speed with low revs
naturalistic Andre wants to put the roof
down with a normal 911 convertible you
can just open the roof while driving at
speeds up to 50 kilometers an hour if he
tries that here nothing happens so like
with the first target he's going to have
to pull over and stop before he can open
the roof but the new targets roof is
electrically controlled okay Stan fan
complexin Stewart and calm as done
commander stuff electric Earthman from
1995 to 2013 Porsche dispensed with its
classic Targa soft top in favor of a
panoramic sliding glass roof but in 2014
it reinvented the roll bar design with
soft top after the engineers in
Stuttgart
found a way to open and close the top
automatically at the push of a button
the roof folds away neatly behind the
backseat
what we're here for must income as Andre
is now stopped it's the ideal chance to
take a closer look at the new interior
there's a new infotainment panel which
he thinks looks more chic than the old
one then there's the stick shift with a
few buttons underneath for various
functions the drive mode switches that
used to be here are now on the steering
wheel which Andre likes more than he'd
expected but he believes Porsche has
made a huge blunder in its choice of
materials in a car that costs at least
130 1000 euros in Germany such a
prominent feature should not be made of
plastic
Metallica few design I think winstrol
there are a few cosmetic changes to the
exterior but it stays true to the
overall look of the 911
the rear bumper sports active air
outlets the air for the turbocharger is
drawn in through the optimized grille on
the engine hood and then there's the
sound
that's good when andriy heard that all
911s were to be fitted with turbocharged
engines he like many other car
enthusiasts was worried that it wouldn't
sound the same but now that he's able to
drive it
he thinks that turbocharger actually
improves the sound when he hits the gas
now especially with a roof down come on
here
Ansgar ski filing the car you
the hookman timmy he can hear a slight
whistle in the background and he finds
that really nice because he can hear the
mechanics at work he also feels the
sport exhaust system helps compensate
for the loss of the naturally aspirated
engine
another significant consolation the
torque has increased by 60 Newton meters
Porcia says the maximum torque of 500
Newton meters is available from as low
as 1700 revs per minute on the old
naturally aspirated engine the highest
torque level was only just kicking in
when the new ones finishing funny
motorcar death still Andrei says he has
the feeling the turbo has caused the 911
some power in the lower rpm range but he
says you soon get past that and then in
keeping with Porsche it's super fast
this dish said the latest overhaul of
Porsches classic sports car is appalled
many purists once again but at the end
of the day the bottom line remains
unchanged Porsche has once again set
standards in sportscar construction
managing to move with the times while
still maintaining its prized tradition
the new Targa with roll bar is a prime
example of that
magazine andré sums up that the target
for s is a very expensive car with a few
flaws
would he still buy it absolutely he
feels the classic design is timeless and
loves to watch the roof opening and
closing it might be more straightforward
to just lift the roof off and put it in
the trunk but with a car of this price
you expect a fully automated system and
he thinks Porsches solution is fantastic
AHA Tashia Xia spectacular you loose